tonight's event I'm pleased to say is
co-sponsored by two friends of ours here
at Wordsworth Chester Atkins who a
former congressman from Massachusetts
currently is head of ATS ventures based
in Concord and in Boston and Chet is a
regular friend of ours here at where
it's worth and we're delighted as always
to be his partner in tonight's event and
as well I would like to thank ray Howell
and Howell Communications for helping to
make tonight's event possible to
introduce our guest author tonight I am
very pleased and honored to welcome
Patricia McGovern Patricia McGovern is
executive vice president for external
affairs at Kerr group which is an
integrated system of quality health care
serving the individual family and
community and it's comprised of a number
of local hospitals including Deaconess
Mount Auburn New England Baptist and
Deaconess well Fame among others and
Patricia McGovern as I'm sure you know
from 1984 to 1992 served as chair of the
Senate committee ways and means and we
are very pleased that she could join us
tonight please join me in welcoming
Patricia McGovern thank you thank you
I'm delighted to be here with all of you
and delighted to welcome our friends on
c-span this is being broadcast on c-span
and I'm one of those people who as I
flick the dial always stop and watch
some of the wonderful authors who
present on c-span so that makes tonight
especially exciting it's my privilege
tonight to introduce maureen des l is
going to speak to us and she's told me
she will be happy to take some questions
when she's finished she's a very
interesting woman she is a graduate of
Boston College and holds not one but two
graduate degrees from Boston University
one in education from the School of
Education and one in journalism from the
School of Public Communication I met her
many years ago when she was a reporter
for the Boston Business Journal when her
specialty was actually covering health
she went on and worked for the Boston
Phoenix and now is a writer she writes
features
for the Boston Globe when I was asked to
do this introduction I was delighted and
I asked for a little information and I'm
going to take the liberty of just
reading you something that I got because
frankly it resonated with me so much so
forgive me for this this simply says
inspired by her frustration and
ambivalence in the way Irish heritage is
observed on st. Patrick's Day in the
United States Marine dazzle has spent
much time in both Ireland and in Irish
American sections of the United States
talking with old and young rich and poor
to really get at the heart of what it
means to be Irish in America and to deal
with this wonderful very rich history
she talks in her book about everything
from Catholicism to Irish mother's
drinking philanthropy and the arts and
Shikari he creates really a completely
original format to discuss the Irish in
America I as many of you have read some
wonderful books on Irish in America a
wonderful Bill Shannon book which is
probably the seminal book about the
Irish it's colliculi called the American
Irish and he at one time was the
ambassador from the United States to
Ireland it's a terrific book and I've
finished as many of you with a cahill
book on how the Irish saved civilization
my fond wish for marine Desalle is this
book does as well as the Tom Cahill book
it's Irish America coming into clover
the evolution of a people and a culture
it is my very real pleasure to present
to you marine to Zell
Thank You Pat I'm really pleased that
Pat introduced me here for a number of
reasons because she exemplifies two of
the things that I was most delighted to
not uncover but delve into in this book
which is the spirit of public service
and strong resilient women so thank you
I'm gonna read since it is the Green
season I'm going to read a little bit
about st. Patrick's Day week and in the
and the image the development of the
image of the Irish in this call in this
country and I think I'll just stop at
various points because you know I mean
we'd rather talk couldn't then read
aloud and this is from the first chapter
each year in early March the mud thaws
the days lengthen and the advertisers
roll out the images of shamrocks
party-hardy leprechauns and
freckle-faced inebriate st. Patrick's
Day is fast approaching and the
competition is keen to sell beer and
spirits by suggesting an Irish brand
endorsement a seal of approval of sorts
from the ethnic group known to over
imbibe st. Patrick's Day advertising is
soui generous in the realm of niche
marketing and a slogan the Leo Burnett
company came up with to sell beer one
year explains why was Irish
I had a Schlitz the exception that
proves the rule that unflattering ethnic
images are far too offensive to use in
the American business of selling no sane
advertiser would create a commercial for
Florida condominiums saying Jewish it
cost less and none would put together a
white-shoe financial sir
an ad for a white shoe financial
services house suggesting that you take
the sting out of investing and have
wasps watch your money obnoxious
character get yours of the clever Jew
the pretty panty frenching excuse me you
get my air quotes okay penny-pinching
protestant and inscrutable asians have
mercifully disappeared from the american
mainstream the irish boozers still Bob's
about in media media flotsam not because
some pernicious prejudice keeps the
cliche afloat but because Irish
Americans endorse it
drinking two wretched excess is a
time-honored tradition on st. Patrick's
Day in the United States an annual
occasion and which a splendid heritage
is reduced to a sentimental slur of
imagined memory fine feeling and faux
Irish talismans and traditions polar air
sets
EERE SAT Z on the American day when
everyone is Irish lucky lasses imputed
Paddy's parade on urban Avenue is
carrying clovers and silent hearts
leering leprechauns service symbols of
Irish wit and cunning Marcus mawkish
music and fight songs pay tribute to the
Irish spirit and public drunkenness
passes for Irish pride the New York st.
Patrick's Day parade which has long made
a concerted effort to cult counter this
cultural clowning is a caricature in its
own right it's a solemn quasi
militaristic display of staunch Roman
Catholicism self-righteousness and Irish
republicanism that's recognized around
the world as a symbol of Irish culture
when in fact it's no such thing
the pageant reflects nothing so much as
the membership and mindset of the
Ancient Order of Hibernians
the all-male fraternal society who
organized the parade and it once led an
unsuccessful campaign to keep America
safe from the Abbey Theatre
today they bar the equally insidious and
threatening gay and lesbian organization
from their line of march the essence and
ethos of the New York parade were
vividly expressed on a gusty Sun warm
March 17th morning in 1999 when the late
Cardinal John O'Connor greeted Irish
screen actress Maureen O'Hara on the
steps of st. Patrick's Cathedral was
conservative catholicism meets the quiet
man
now the Ancient Order of Hibernians
plate of surprisingly large part in the
development of the image of the Irish in
the United States descendants of
dreamers and tale tellers in the land of
myth and money the American Irish early
on developed a capacity for
romanticizing their heritage and
sentimentalizing themselves the throngs
who fled Ireland's great hunger and
their children had little choice but to
reinvent who they were
the famine immigrants who spilled out of
coffin ships were dressed in rags weak
with hunger and numb with the fresh
memory of corpse filled work houses
skeletal children and tales of
cannibalism they were pre-modern
peasants homeless nation lists and all
but hopeless after a grim sea passage to
an unwelcoming land I don't think a lot
of people realized that when that the
Irish when they got here were really
refugees we're really boat people and
that you know they're worth rungs and
throngs of them washing up on these
shores and there were no social services
to speak of they were not only were they
unwelcome but there was nothing here
there was no welfare state there was no
church there was nothing else they had
to invent all that and themselves like
immigrants who would later take their
place on the bottom of the rung of the
economic ladder they represented much of
what American society up Hett abhorred
they were Celts not Anglo Saxons papist
not Protestants rebels fighting to expel
America's motherland from their homeland
they were communal in a land of vaunted
individualist achievers drinkers at the
dawn of the American Temperance Movement
a gregarious and boisterous people who
showed little interest in American
enterprise but loved politics newspaper
and magazine illustrators who provided
visual definition for the pre tabloid
age borrowed from British newspaper
pages in vaudeville stages to reflect
the prevailing opinion drawing ape-like
Irish drunken paddies menacing mix and
surly biddies Thomas Nast who is famous
for the drawing that the donkey and the
and the elephant and Santa Claus these
were his images was incapable of drawing
an Irishman that was not a cross between
a professional boxer and an orangutan
an on-stage the Irishman was essentially
a [ __ ] with a shillelagh there were
many many staged Irish patties who would
play themselves as well as Sambo's in
blackface minstrel shows on stages in
New York Patti and [ __ ] had a lot in
common they were childlike musical
hapless exuberant and irrationally loyal
to their employers in the words of music
a story and William H Williams gradually
vaudeville helped turn Patti Mick and
Biddy into Pat Mike and Bridget and
vaudeville to be Irish was to dance
Irish immigrants immigrants brought to
the traditional step dancing to America
where it became part of theatrical
dancing Irish step-dancing provided the
start for more than one
twentieth-century tap dancer George M
Cohan began his career with the same
Irish steps his father had used in the
theater I don't think a lot of people
realize that Cohan started as a as a
step dancer his family were on the
vaudeville circuit and so did Cagney the
reason that he could play George M Cohan
in Yankee Doodle Dandy was that he had
learned the same the same Irish step
step dances I go on to talk about the
development the sort of gradual
sanitization of the of the Irish
American image in the late 19th century
and alive it happened through the
character of the stage Irishman who is
still with us very much today
the Irish in vaudeville started sort of
making fun of themselves as these grand
gregarious slap-happy drunken people and
everyone loved it it was really quite
remarkable and simultaneous with this
this producer an impresario who is
really credited with inventing melodrama
he was the first producer to tie anyone
to a railroad tracks d anbu Seco arrived
and he brought a cast of Irish
caricatures in plays such as the shokran
the Colleen born in era nob hope that
were wild romp through spectacular
country sides where the peasants were
wily and self-sufficient and daredevil
rogues out with their British overlords
with Blarney and out my new
with brawn at the time no less alike
than Henry James reviewing the shock run
in the nation compared it favorably to
standard Irish fare at the time calling
it a portrayal of love devotion
self-sacrifice humble but heroic bravery
and brimming with Irish Bon Ami and
irony
it was those characteristics mixed with
staged Irish slap happiness and tippling
that came to define a consummate Irish
American persona the self-effacing
regular guy and I go on to talk about
some other producers and impresarios in
the late 19th century which unless I was
at I was in San Francisco over the
weekend and there were a lot of real
junkies they had all the music I thought
I was bad but I'll skip some of this the
Ancient Order of Hibernians tried to try
to rid this stage of demeaning Irish
caricatures Pat and Mike and so forth
and so on at the same time they sort of
extended the definition of what
demeaning was and it included
productions by the Abbey Theatre who
sent a troupe touring under the name the
Irish players to the United States in
1911 1912 the Hibernians who passed a
resolution as sailing Yeats sing and
other so-called Irish dramatists tried
to organize boycotts of Playboy in the
Western world in major cities the Irish
player boycotts were not successful
which is not to say the Hibernians were
alone on the night playboy opened in
Boston a young rose Fitzgerald Kennedy
said blushing and squirming in her seat
years later she told the historian Doris
Kearns Goodwin that no matter how hard
she tried she could not help but feel
embarrassed by the coarse dialog and
sorted portrayal of Irish people as
drunken sods and quarreling fools for it
was those qualities of poverty dirt and
sloth that Yankees maintained were
characteristic of the Boston Irish but
as offended as she was by the play
Kennedy was far more embarrassed but a
tasteless response of many of her
kinsmen who in their anger began
throwing tomatoes at the stage and
hissing booing and loudly John Devoy a
Fenian editor of the Gaelic American in
New York
against this play and stood up in the
middle of it and claimed son of a [ __ ]
that's not Irish he of course had not
been in Ireland for more than 30 years
the notion that non idealized portrayals
of the Irish were not offensive but in
fact not Irish was touted by
nationalists and it held considerable
appeal for upwardly mobile Irish
Americans as historian Thomas Brown
explains it much of the support for
Irish nationalism in this country was
motivated not so much by an interest in
Ireland's political future as by a
desire for respectability Ireland's
servitude to Britain was seen as a
stigma of inferiority a rationale for
Irish second-class standing in the New
World
what started to happen at this point is
that Tin Pan Alley embraced Irishness
you can praise the idea of the Emerald
Isle and of the good old Irish American
guy a lot of the songs that many
Americans think of as traditional Irish
songs like toora loora loora that's an
Irish lullaby when Irish eyes are
smiling were written on Tin Pan Alley
for four broad for Broadway shows and it
was quite remarkable that for example in
1916 the year of the Easter Rising that
the songs on Broadway included Ireland
must be heaven for my mother came from
there and enter loora loora that made
its its debut and gradually
sentimentality became Irish America's
signature style as the same tenor John
McCormick's recordings celebrating Irish
mother's and home spilled out of
middle-class parlors theatres and music
halls the meeting of two stereotypes the
affable Irish American and the Emerald
Isle of Enchantment represented a
welcome change for the socially
ascendant Irish middle class at the dawn
of the 20th century Irish meant
something very different than it had in
the United States fifty years before
paddy who traversed the urban terrain
and the eponymous wagon had evolved into
Pat the driver a fine fellow if he kept
him away from the bottle who begot the
back-slapping glad-handing ever
professional Irishman Biddy was Brigid
and her household was becoming a
respectable place
the Irish could now sing songs like who
put the overalls in mrs. Murphy's
chowder because not that many people
could remember what the bad old days
when there was only one kettle in the
kitchen for both the washing and the fan
of cooking now the poster boy for this
sort of professional glad-handing irish
america of course was George M cohan
I'm sorry I keep doing this I'm taking
antihistamines the song-and-dance man it
was probably a lot better today known
today for his songs than for his shows
there's a wonderful movie with that I
referred to earlier a biopic of cohan
where James James Cagney plays him and
it is it's famous for the whole thing
but also there's a scene in here in
which he gets the Medal of Honor
Franklin D Roosevelt is is awarding
Cohan slash Cagney the middle of honor
and he's escorted into Roosevelt's
office and you just see the back but I
forget who the actor is the back of the
back of the head and he sits down and
George M goes through his biography they
come back and Roosevelt says that's one
thing I've always admired about you
Irish Americans you carry your love of
country like a flag right out in the
open and the Cagney goes goes back out
and it's escorted down the stick
escorted out and down the stairs by this
black Butler and it's really a a
consummate image of the extent to which
the Irish were accepted but only on
certain terms at that point gradually
though what word had been defined as as
kind of Irish American characteristics
that what Cohan has and what Cagney had
became increasingly identified with
American characteristics by the time
this movie melding the careers of the
two great entertainers was released
cohan was an American performer and
impresario Cagney was an American movie
icon in the making the significance of
their ethnicity had diminished in the
twice and 30s the traits associated with
Irish American character street-smart
talked tough talking funny irreverent
were increasingly identified as American
what happened was that America
pop culture absorbed the sunshine in
Irish identity the humor the width the
musicality the dance and it left the
shadows in slack the Irish in the movies
gradually became identified with what
we're seen as American virtues humor
bravery loyalty dedication to the
greatest greater good and the avatar of
all of these qualities was the Irish
movie priest now everybody talks about
Spencer Tracy and Bing Crosby but my
particular favorite Irish movie priest
was Pat O'Brien in in the fighting 69th
which is a really hokey but wonderful
movie about the fame troop that started
in in the Civil War and was in the
spanish-american war the Irish troop and
in this particular movie the troop was
led by William Wild Bill Donovan played
by George Brent and Cagney plays a
cowardly soldier Jerry Plunkett opposite
O'Brien's benevolent chaplain fighting
father Duffy who's for theater fans here
whose statue is in across from cohan's
in Times Square the only two statues in
Times Square are cohan and father Duffy
in this Irish Great War movie features
one of the more splendid examples of the
central casting standard the American
army platoon as melting pot as a Jewish
soldier who's claimed his name was
Murphy so he could join the famed
regiment lies dying
O'Brien reads to him portions of the
Kaddish and recites a line in Hebrew
here we have American courage and
tolerance beating loudly out of the
great big heart of an Irish priest later
on in the movie in his deathbed scene
with O'Brien Cagney was given into
father Duffy's urging returned to the
front and shown his bravery but taking a
fatal hit looks up at his Savior here on
earth and says to a bright I've just
been talking to your boss the movie
moment captures the cultural sensibility
in a one-liner it's tragedy 11 with
humor thoroughly in the Irish tradition
distilled in a wisecrack delivered in a
New York accent so American culture had
really really absorbed it meanwhile the
movies that function on a certain level
as super ordinary public relations
campaigns for American Catholicism or
vibrato
if hollywood's production code an
industry self-regulation measure written
by a jesuit Daniel Lord and enforced
from the early 1930s through the 1950s
largely by a wheeling dealing Irish
Catholic Joseph breehn breehn brokered a
meeting of minds or at least a pragmatic
interest between Hollywood producers
many of whom were Jewish and Catholic
Bishops who forged their unlikely
alliance because neither could live with
the others unchecked influence over the
populace the church field feared
Hollywood hedonism almost as much as the
movie moguls dreaded the power of
Catholic boycotts at the box office and
neither Hollywood nor the Catholic
hierarchy wanted the federal government
to regulate what was seen on the screen
the code and the movies reflected church
concerns censoring sex often to an
absurd degree de glamorizing violence
and anti-communism they also help
demystify the church and present a
genial down-to-earth and duty bound
priests personas like Tracy O'Brien and
Bing Crosby in going my way does anybody
have any questions with at this point or
anything just say well I'll just
I will just keep reading for a moment in
the night and then I will stop in 1952
a century after their fleet fitted four
bears were dancing in blackface wielding
patty props Gene Kelly and Donald
O'Connor starting a musical tour de
force singing in the rain
bear Irishness was incidental Kelly at
that point was an utterly American
success story
so was Grace Kelly the golden girl who
became a princess so for that matter
where Jackie Gleason who introduced the
world that year to Ralph
ed Norton Alice and Trixie on his CBS
show on another TV hear of the time was
Archbishop Fulton J Sheen whose popular
TV show life is worth living debuted on
the Dumont Network that year what was
recognizably Irish in America by the
early 1950s was the quiet man John
Ford's tall tale and Technicolor
starring Wayne O'Hara and Barry
Fitzgerald Fort Kenton constructed a
Potemkin village in one of the more
depressed reaches of a depressed country
to film the movie which is set in the
Emerald Isle of Enchantment where I
smile and pure or wiser folk live in
that
cottages seemingly sustained by Irish
midst turf fires a local pub and the
routine drawl point was the son of Irish
immigrants and he his work obviously
itched our ideas of the West Monument
Valley and in the movie-going world but
with the notable he seemed to lose his
mind when he when he took on Irish
subjects I mean he just he lost all all
and I was I spoke with Joseph McBride
who's doing a biography with him over
last weekend he maintains this isn't
true but you look at any of these these
movies I mean it's always got drawling
boozing drunken Irishman just you know
time after time and the quiet man is one
form of sentimentality the other form of
sentimentality is his movie version of
the last hurrah which is supposed to be
the great Irish American novel and I
would beg to differ because I think that
it is as sentimental as the worst of the
worst of the subculture and I also
object to the fact that that it is in
the tradition of Irish American
literature and actually television shows
from what I can see I haven't yet seen
the fighting Fitzgerald's when the women
are always dead the last hurrah
think of it the dear departed mother in
the dear departed wife are the only
women in that book all right I don't
think there are any women and the
fighting Fitzgerald's fortunately Eugene
O'Neill was at the Abbey Theatre in 1911
it when they when they came to New York
and was able to establish a tradition
obviously of his own although O'Neill
for his entire life was accused of being
anti Irish even though he wrote what was
probably or what many people consider
and I consider the great Irish American
text long day's journey and tonight
Irish mists just about faded into into
the into the woodwork and in the 1960s
after the Irish had turned stereotypes
that we used to stigmatize them into
cultural currency they started being
portrayed as the bad guys there were the
police and the priests and the symbols
of the old order the corrupt cops the
racist the nutty anti-communist says
Timothy Maher points if they became
representatives of white ethnic
conservatives starting with the cops and
the Godfather and Serpico now the
assumption that the Irish represented
the old order was not without premise
Irish Catholic communism was given
virulent voice by Joe McCarthy and
expounded by leaders of the church like
New York's Francis Cardinal Spellman
then in the 1970s an ugly race hating
Irish image came to the forest the
battle over forced public school
desegregation began in Boston a
television Archie Bunker wasn't supposed
to be Irish was there anyone in the
country who looked at and listened to
Carroll and O'Connor and thought it got
reminds me of a wasp I knew from
Minneapolis Robert De Niro played a semi
corrupt Monsignor and the ultimate heart
had reactionary infuriated by Peace Love
and tie-dye who massacres a bunch of
hippies was a guy named Joe with an
Irish last name meanwhile the people of
Ireland were portrayed as cartoons
Darby O'Gill and the little people or
fearsome people said in Patriot Games
IRA members became standard Hollywood
villains in the 1980s only Arab
terrorists work more crudely portrayed
but somehow through all of this
Irish humor books have always found
publishers there's a 1999 book for
example called how to be Irish even if
you already are that typifies this genre
it features an irreverent guide to Irish
figures of speech Irish coat of arms two
black eyes and a bloody nose and a
chapter called how to eat Irish which is
illustrated with a picture of a potato
sitting on top of a six-pack and opens
with the witticism the great hunger is
not only the name given to the agony of
the Irish population during the potato
famine but to the condition of many a
tourist in
Ireland today readers who don't find
famine jokes funny mic yet a bigger kick
out of the tongue-in-cheek treatment of
hunger strikers terrorist Terence
McSweeney and Bobby Sands in the same
chapter
Volare published this extended bad show
in early 1999 and reputable booksellers
not this one okay
displayed it during the st. Patrick's
Day sale season in March Passover was
coming up in a few weeks that year and
some merchants also had tables
exhibiting Jewish books not surprisingly
there were no jokey tomes about tourism
in Israel filled with anti-semitic
stereotypes and landbase of Jewish
martyrs to be found on those tables I'm
gonna stop there does anyone have any
questions or comments yes or the Irish
stereotype continuing in America the
fighting Fitzgerald's I caught maybe a
few minutes of it has a great act of
Brian Dennehy I'm in Boston recently and
fabulous yeah and this is a I just
briefly saw the television for a piece
of it and I was very disgusted why you
mentioned other ethnic groups I sort of
buy the stereotyping and if people are
inappropriate everybody gets excited why
is the Irish or rather the Irish number
cannot buy it and why the Irish protest
why don't they why does it continue why
do they continue I think I think some of
it has to do with the fact that it was
it really was sanitized it was really in
the interest of organized Irish rhe the
Hibernians and some of the Nationalists
and so forth to keep this image the
other thing and this is not a subculture
that's been chronicled very much I'm for
all that the presence and all that we
supposedly know there is not a lot of
history about the American Irish and
Thomas O'Connor out at Boston College
has talked about how difficult it is to
do because people didn't think they were
important enough to write down their own
stories they were worried about
committing the sin of pride and this is
you know this is genuinely it's really
hard for historians to do there was not
a lot of literature and I talked a
little bit in the chapter about O'Neill
being accused of being anti Irish all
the time and that you know that
continues and it continues to this day I
mean you will see respected academics
even now taking issue with Mary Gordon's
novels because they're angry you know
which is a charge that would never be
level leveled in a male novelist the
other thing is that the the Irish
Catholic Church was was culture for this
subculture for a very long time and so
there I think that some of the
traditions that might have developed
that have developed as a methyl groups
didn't necessarily fortunately I think
that the arrival for all that the
fighting Fitzgerald's I mean we have had
a veritable Renaissance of theater and
literature and and memoir in recent
years that have given some depth and
resonance to this culture but that book
how to be Irish was published in 1999
that's rather yes you think the Irish in
America are out I wish in the Irish you
mean trying to over Irish them the Irish
I think there is an element of that of
people trying to be more Irish in the
Irish but I think it's a construct I
think it's it's a notion of Irishness
that that sort of developed on its own
without a lot a lot a lot of outside
influence I mean the perfect example is
the American Saint Patrick's Day Parade
there's never been anything like that in
Ireland yeah just so where did this come
from the Irish that the st. Patrick's
Day in the Dublin parade I thought it
was it was just a not very entertaining
parade at all was is rather dull well
yeah I mean if it wasn't for the Boy
Scouts the Girl Scouts they wouldn't
have a parade but this is all changed in
in recent years there's now a four-day
festival in Dublin which unfortunately I
guess got cancelled this year because of
foot foot and foot mouth and the
four-day festival has some of the best
theatrical producers involved and it's
interesting they were deliberately
inclusive I
think it was either in the first or
second st. Patrick's Day parade in
Dublin they had a black soccer player as
the name Paul McGrath as the the grand
grand marshal and gay floats win prizes
in Dublin and in Cork and it's you know
very festive very inclusive very unlike
our best-known st. Patrick's Day parades
yes don't you think it's possible that
the image of the Irish is defined by the
end claves of the Irish you grew up
around the country I grew up in the
Midwest yes coming out here 25 years ago
I found that what were tendencies in my
family were you know big directions in
Boston what sorts of things
well Boyle T for example humor a sense
of caring about the people in your
immediate circle mm-hmm those were I
think weakened somewhat or broaden
somewhat by living in other parts of the
country and it's and it's the end claves
that define this image that you're
talking there 50 million Americans of
Irish extraction and I don't think all
of them you know fit that image or or
believe in that no not at all um I think
that that Irishness is defined to a
great extent by Boston and-and-and the
New York parade which are symbolic of it
but they're really not representative of
the whole country as you know you know
from growing up in the Midwest now we
are you from in the Midwest big
population at st. Paul yeah yeah big
population in California yes but it
wasn't till I got out here that I began
to understand you know some of my own
tendons you recognize like that I'm sure
you did too and I think your book makes
that point yeah I have a whole chapter
about just what Irishness means the
different things that means around the
country it's quite different when you
get out of Boston anybody else
I have a question regarding the desire
of some people to adopt the Irish
American culture I know that I had a
grandmother who liked to sort of say
that she was an Irish Catholic American
who turns out she was sort of a Scottish
maybe it had something to do with the
Kennedys and falling in love with them
but I don't know if this is something
you've come across much well you know
demographically you know that census
figure that you mentioned 50 million
there's 44 million I mean I've just been
focusing on some on some of the negative
the negative stuff and the image but
demographically more people claim Irish
heritage in the United States that is
statistically possible and one of the
things that that I found what was that a
lot of people who grew up as many
Americans do you know half Italian half
Irish or half french-canadian in western
Massachusetts identify themselves as
Irish and I think was John Steinbeck who
said well he was half Irish but that
strain doesn't seem to dilute very well
and you know some of it of course was I
mean the the Catholic Church was an
Irish Catholic Church and still is I
mean that was very much in the image of
Ireland as a matter of fact they weren't
very nice to people who came who kind of
came along after themself it's it's it's
the laboratory it's also you know I mean
the best of the best of this culture is
a lot of fun I mean you can see why it
defines some of the what I consider the
best in America which is a Galit
arianism and the regular guy and and so
forth so maybe that's why but she's not
alone recording these demographers
recent years as you mentioned we have
seen a lot of change in the way we view
Irish culture in this culture there's
been a lot more acknowledgment and
affirmation both in literature and
socially to what the the the the
benefits of an Irish heritage are why do
you think that changed so it seemed to
me suddenly somewhere around the mid
late
why did that change so much do you think
from these earlier images that you write
about I think to two really critical
things happen one was the decline of the
Catholic Church in influence in people's
actually I think there are three of the
Catholic Church in in importance and
influence I mean that really was the
culture for a lot of people for a long
time I also think that the arrival in
the in the 1980s of the immigrant
population that I refer to in other
people referred to as the new Irish
which was more educated more European
oriented population they weren't it
wasn't that large demographically but I
think they made a huge difference I mean
there are um newspapers magazines
theater companies pubs new kinds of
music festivals and also just a live
Irishness in the United States for the
first time and I think that the third
probably not quite as influential but I
think that you know I mean Irish
Americans are phenomenally economically
successful right now and that has
allowed people who might have resist you
know to put money into it to look at
things and also never underestimate the
self-interest of baby boomers you know I
can say this being one I mean we've got
kids now and we want to be able to tell
our kids about their heritage and I
think that's been that's been large as
well
it's pleasant change though it's just
it's warm a political front this is
several years ago quite a few years ago
it was you know Irish pub talking to the
Irish bartender there and talking about
Ireland so well my my son getting
married to an Irish woman Oh where's he
from I said she's from Belfast he said
Oh Northern Ireland and he walked away
Irish born yes and he's looking with the
politics it seems to me that I mean when
you talk hours you're talking Catholic
that's actually not true I know it yeah
I know and and you know what it seems to
me that there's a a prejudice among the
American Irish against the belfast
northern
yeah it sort of doesn't count yeah it's
not ireland its england yeah in a way
it's it's very it's very odd
i mean my name is is an unusual name and
it's a derivation of the name Dalzell
which was from Portadown and people's in
yeah somehow that somehow that doesn't
count
i don't know i'm but but that's that's
part of the sort of sentimentality about
the Emerald Isle of enchantment in a way
I mean you don't want to deal with with
things that interfere with that yeah you
make some comments about the
irish-american in terms of their
economics of success and philanthropy
love chip this is one of my absolute
favorite favorite parts of doing this
book first of all that the notion that
that is perpetuated particularly by the
New York st. Patrick's Day parade that
this is a politically conservative
blue-collar population is nonsense Irish
Americans have been college educated
white collar and extremely successful I
think only among white ethnics only Jews
have earned more money for about 30
years now and it was true that was true
longer in the Midwest and the West and
it's recently I mean just look around
Boston we you know we can certainly see
that philanthropy I started looking into
some of the people who've recently made
fortunes and there's a man named Charles
Feeney who was given away the second
largest sum of money in the United
States right after Ted Turner he did it
all anonymously and I started to
research this and I spoke with Joe Leary
of the Irish American partnership and
some other people who said this is very
typical even some of the people that we
know around Boston such as John
Cullinane and and Tom Flatley and so
forth who support causes quite visibly
do a lot of it anonymously
and this is it as it turns out a long
tradition in Ireland and it's still
going on in Ireland as a matter of fact
they're having problems in Ireland
because they're trying to figure out how
to how to track this and people just
give money away the the people the
people of Ireland give away more per
capita and and spend more and have more
people in their families involved in
social services than almost anyone else
in the world and that has continued here
I crunched some numbers I had a
sociologist help me crunch some numbers
from the National Opinion Research
Centre on giving and volunteering and
hands down Irish Catholics just no
matter what their income was gave a lot
and volunteered a whole lot of time and
I spoke with sister Mary Oates at it at
Regis College who's an economist who's
written about Catholic philanthropy and
her explanation is that it that it's
really from two traditions is the church
which the Irish had to build themselves
in Ireland I mean the British weren't
going to build it for them and then when
they got here and and this intense
communalism and then when they got here
you know they had to do it all over
again and they didn't have any money so
it was hands on there's a long tradition
of hands on giving which is you know if
you've got a culture that doesn't like
that doesn't like to talk about itself
and show off you don't know these things
but thanks
do you see in terms of you've talked
about the Irish images kind of a
monolith you see a difference breaking
down in class with you know rising group
of affluent Irish who like Riverdance
and send their children to Ireland
junior year abroad but there's also you
know a strong working-class Irish many
who might you know is very supportive of
the traditional Irish st. Patrick's Day
parade do you do you see a split
developing in images and attitudes about
Irishness based on class I think that
there's some of that I mean I think that
symbolic ethnicity is as I mean yeah
you've got the is it an Aaron sweater or
a you know a hat with you know a plastic
green hat and you know fine I don't I
don't object to to the images so much
per se as the really demeaning once I
mean the nineteenth-century stereotypes
of the fighting Irishman and drunken
Irishman that are paraded as a points of
pride on st. Patrick's Day but no there
is there's definitely a class there's
class and it's that's particularly true
in Boston I mean what it does Lukas call
the busing an Irish family feud between
the people who were still in the city
and those who had gone off and into the
suburbs is particularly strong here yeah
anybody else I want to say son the
familial tendencies be good but don't be
better than your father you know watch
out for alcohol it's a double-edged
sword and some of the stereotypes have a
basis is all realities experience oh
yeah and and the the oath of swearing
off liquor for life began in Ireland I
believe that's dedicating it to the
church could you comment on some of
those things how they play out
you must I start with family or alcohol
alcohol and and I've been I've been
doing some radio in last week and it's
inevitably something that people ask is
it true where did this you know why the
Irish are the inertia nation or of
people of alcoholic and you know like
every stereotype or characteristic if we
like them we call them characteristics
if we don't like them we call them
stereotypes right
okay so alcoholism there's absolutely no
doubt that Irish Catholics in the United
States drink more than the average like
22 percent more um demographically than
your average Irish Americans however
that is also true of Americans of
English descent it is also true of
Americans of Slavic descent who I
believe you know drink a little more um
one of the things that I did some
research on excuse me on drinking and
what caught you know causes of
alcoholism and so forth what's notable
there are many things that are that are
notable about this the Irish and Ireland
drink more than the drink less than the
Irish in America when you look at charts
of alcohol consumption rates in Europe
they're always in the middle
the French are way up high nobody thinks
of the French as big as being you know
raging alcoholics but their cirrhosis
rates psychosis rates etc etc are much
higher than in Ireland in the northern
countries on the Scandinavian countries
are very high as well
George valiant who's I guess kind of the
acknowledged expert on alcoholism over
here at Harvard said that there are
three things that predispose someone to
to developing problems with alcohol one
is a family history I mean it's it's
scary but if you're adopted by
teetotalers you still and your natural
parent was an alcoholic you still have
seven times as great a chance of
becoming alcoholic another is growing up
in a culture that condones drinking but
does not teach children to drink
responsibly
and this is one and he cites both the
Irish and American Indians as cultures
in which first of all they were both
colonized I think we tend to forget that
that when you look around the world now
I mean where the highest alcoholism
rates are in places like South Africa
that have been colonized but but beyond
that for all this you know weddings and
wakes and so forth and so on the Irish
don't teach their kids to drink at all
and they covertly praise drunkenness and
men drinking groups which is like never
a good idea away from their family and
away from food and you know these these
cultures over and over are you know
they're the alcoholic cultures and so
but the other thing is let's not talk
about it I mean if you pretend I quote a
woman in the book who went into
Alcoholics Anonymous and said she went
to her mother-in-law and apologized for
what she considered to be some very bad
behavior and her mother-in-law said to
her it's the curse of the Irish and we
don't need to talk about it and there is
in certain parts of the country in
alcoholics Anonymous a syndrome known as
CIA which is Catholic Irish alcoholism
which is apparently different than other
kinds of alcoholism because as a
counselor I I interviewed Bill Regan
said this is a culture that thinks that
the light at the end of the tunnel is a
train and you're also supposed to suffer
and you're supposed to bear up and
you're just supposed to keep moving on
and liquor plays you know plays a dual a
dual role there which is you know I mean
it is swage as some of that some of that
not talking and some of that pain which
is inevitable in life and it also if it
gets out of control and this is another
thing that happens in Irish families
they simply refuse to discuss it cut off
relations and and don't talk about it
some more
which I think you're onto something with
this idea of colonization mmm because if
you stood out in a crowd yes exactly
exactly no I mean everybody blames the
church for that the working title of
this book was who do you think you are
because anybody who grew up on in an
Irish Catholic school system background
and so forth heard that over and over
and over again don't let me do you think
you are it's a real put-down but it's
not just the church it was definitely
the the community you didn't want to
stand out somebody was gonna pick on you
and then when you got here you moved
it's the downside of the loyalty is the
downside of always seeing the underdog
is is this self-effacement Pete Hamill
calls it the green ceiling you know I
mean you never you never you never want
to get too too highfalutin or to above
yourself dangerous yeah yeah an old IRA
it was dangerous yeah for a certain
period
III think it did in the neighborhood I
mean you I mean Hamill talks in his
memoir a drinking life about if you had
your eyes on a bigger prize well you
know what do you think this isn't good
enough for you come on
and there getting drunk was a way of
showing that he was a regular guy great
syndrome okay thank you very much